what do you see what's going through the
heads of these two leaders as they stand
next to each other I think that right
now they're trying to download what
happened last night David mentioned they
had that dinner at the Blair House and
this is keeping with a White House
strategy that started in Beijing last
year and even sunnylands in California
and their first visit together in 2013
where the President believes the best
way to talk to Xi Jinping the best way
to actually get messages and perhaps
negotiations across is to do it
one-on-one in private settings when
you're in group negotiations it becomes
a talking points festival more or less
what we saw last night was a repeat of
what we saw in Beijing a private dinner
between the two we're undoubtedly
according to White House officials have
spoken to this morning cybersecurity
came up the big issue that everybody's
touting right now is that climate
agreement that you talked about guys and
that started actually in November in
Beijing where they reached a big
agreement that kind of jump-started the
talks for the international climate
talks in Paris in December this kind of
another step in that direction
but again whether its territorial claims
in the East and South China Sea or most
notably cybersecurity right now there
are a lot of major differences here and
this relationship is not on solid ground
at least according to US officials so
there's a lot weighing on not just what
happened last night but also these
bilateral negotiations that'll start
right after the pomp and circumstance
this morning so interesting you know we
had Susan Rice making a major speech at
George Washington University previewing
this visit by President Xi you talking
about the relationship between these two
men again forged as you say at
sunnylands forged in these private
moments together I understand there's
going to be sort of two series of two
parts of the series of bilateral
meetings today one of the two of them
and then a larger one with with the
cabinet as well so it sounds like at
least it you know from a personal
perspective the two of them are maybe
making some progress getting along a bit
better it's interesting David and I was
with the president on the trip to
Beijing last year and you talked to
White House officials about the
relationship between these two men and
the president likes is a strong word
here but I think he's one genuinely
curious about Xi Jinping and the
leadership he's tried to take to the
country that he's currently running but
he also it kind of enjoys the
give-and-take between the two he feels
like they have a candid relationship in
these private meetings they've been able
to speak one-on-one in a way that maybe
leaders of these two countries haven't
in the past I think the president's
focus here and you hear this from all
White House officials is in
on the issues of agreement in this case
its climate it's Afghanistan it's the
Iran talks and then try and work out a
way around the areas of disagreement
I think the concern you hear from
critics right now is that is essentially
open the door to President Xi being more
aggressive on several fronts I think the
White House this is a key key meeting
this is a key visit to see whether or
not that strategy of engagement is
effective or well it's whether it's just
completely fallen flat David bill I'm
thinking back to Copenhagen where Obama
laid so much of his own a personal
political capital put it on the table
there and made a trip to Copenhagen to
try and get some sort of agreement and
who Jintao from China at that point
played the spoiler he refused to meet
one-on-one with any world leaders and
basically he had people run around
trying to make sure an agreement didn't
happen you've been talking about the
personal relationship between these two
leaders what groundwork are they laying
right now to make sure that Paris is
more successful than Copenhagen I think
both of these countries is the two kind
of larger largest pollutants in the
polluting countries in the entire world
our cognizant of the fact that if
there's going to be any type of major
agreement in Paris if Paris is going to
work in a sense they need to be the two
leaders in that I think what the
President sees here it what President
Obama sees here is critics about
cap-and-trade critics about climate have
always said in the last three or four
years even back in 2009 when the
administration was first pushing
cap-and-trade that hey if you don't get
China to come along with you noting that
the United States does matters all it
does is set us back set us at an
economic disadvantage well the big deal
last November when they got China to
agree to kind of top-line emissions
reductions was that hey we got China
with us hopefully this will help pull
India along hopefully this will help
pull other countries along so again
while those disagreements are very
serious on issues like territorial
claims in cyber I think on Climate
laying the groundwork Brendon as you
said for Paris these are the two key
players right now and if these two key
players not only can set realistic
targets set aggressive targets but also
go almost as a united front into Paris
in December I think that sets a tone
that I think maybe a year ago at this
time nobody really thought was in play
yeah so just to recap what we're
watching here there's a Bloomberg
surveillance I'm David rhew
with Brendan Greeley or hearing from our
man in Washington Phil Mattingly we're
looking at photos here pictures here of
the South Lawn of the White House
President Xi Jingping President Obama
greeting people who have come to hear
from the two men there at the White
House before a series of bilateral
meetings take place at the White House
today on president Xi's state visit to
the US will be a state dinner tonight
and of course Phil we've been talking
about climate change and the agreements
in the lead up to Paris but of course in
the background is also China's security
posture the two leaders just walked past
in review what looked to be about a
platoons worth of Marines and then some
Airmen I'm thinking when I see that but
also some very real combat Marines have
been sent to northern Australia which is
which is very obviously a signal to
China as the to go into these talks what
is the state of play it's not good and I
mean that seems like a simplistic way to
put it but if you just watch what's
happened over the last year year and a
half it's really kind of hit a downward
slope that's concerned a lot of US
allies whether it be Japan or Vietnam or
South Korea and it's obviously concerned
u.s. military leaders what's going on
when the South China Sea with the
building of what US intelligence
officials believe or military
installations it's caused a lot of
problems in the relationship the biggest
issue here from White House officials
standpoint is they're not sure what
pushback actually has an impact we've
sent naval vessels the president's Air
Force one flew through the expanded
Chinese air defense zone in April of
last year trying to to make a statement
of some sort and none of that has had an
effect so I think the question going
into this is is there anything the u.s.
can do either in these meetings behind
closed doors or with their kind of
public military posture going forward
that can have any type of impact on what
Xi Jinping's military is doing right now
as of now they've more or less come up
empty and it's kind of one of those
issues that you can get in candid
moments with White House officials them
to acknowledge also something they're
willing to acknowledge US allies in the
region are very uncomfortable about that
fat guys